hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
Aleister McIntyre in his piece playing
persons and moral philosophy is going to
frame things quite deliberately and
understandably in what he calls a told
Mr Aristotelian way this is an address
that he's giving after his seminal work
after virtue where he's endorsing a kind
of overarching Aristotelian project and
Viewpoint and saying that the
alternatives are either Aristotle or
something else and that there's
something else over here the whole bag
of it is going to be less successful for
making sense out of Ethics adequately
not just in an abstract academic sense
but within the context of our culture
and our lives what it is that the as
he's calling it ordinary or everyday
plain person is dealing with and he's
going to advance this claim and really
do a lot to support it that the the
plain person is inevitably or at least
potentially a
proto-aristotelian now he's not
endorsing every single thing that
Aristotle is committed to we see him
later on in the piece saying you know
when Aristotle dismisses Ordinary People
he doesn't have any good Arguments for
that and we're just going to leave that
behind us as we ought to but he is going
to begin from an Aristotelian point of
view as he's going to very explicitly
tell us
and he says that on an Aristotelian view
the questions posed by the moral
philosopher on the one side and the
questions posed by the Plain person are
to an important degree Inseparable now
that's from an Aristotelian view as
McIntyre is construing it in the 20th
century right
he says that it is with questions each
begins each is engaged in inquiry uh the
plain person will often unsystematically
ask what is my good what actions will
achieve it and the moral philosopher is
systematically inquiring what is the
good for human beings and what kind of
actions will achieve these goods and
McIntyre says these are not as easily
separable as we might think the
particular from the universal the
systematic from the unsystematic they're
actually intertwined with each other and
then he says you know somebody might
bring up an objection and he says this
quite early on
so he says uh I might already seem to be
assuming by my references to Aristotle
and Aquinas that insofar as the plain
person becomes a moral philosopher he or
she will at least tend towards becoming
Aristotelian and this might seem to be
question begging and now a little
discursis right I'm not trying to bust
anybody's chops about this but the
traditional meaning of begging the
question doesn't mean raising another
question it means engaging in circular
argumentation you're begging for
precisely what you're supposed to be
proving you're getting somebody to agree
at the start to what they're supposed to
conclude that circular reasoning that's
what question begging traditionally has
meant and that's what McIntyre means by
it so what is this you know translate
into you Aleister McIntyre are already
assuming an Aristotelian point of view
and then you're applying it to the plain
person and and then of course you're
discovering in the playing person and
their moral activities and inquiries an
Aristotelian but it's only there because
you put it there in the first place
buddy and McIntyre says you know
um I am it may be said
usurping the role of a plain person
putting my philosophical words or rather
aristotles and aquinas's philosophical
words into her or his pre-philosophical
mouth but surely the plain person must
be allowed to speak for her himself and
it become whatever kind of philosopher
he or she chooses to be and McIntyre
says this is actually misleading
why now in broad Strokes we can say
because there is no such thing as a just
plain person who has no philosophical
commitments whatsoever
everybody's version of the plain person
the the average guy or gal on the street
is in fact reflecting a point of view
that they are putting forward so he
gives us an example what we could call
the existentialist uh plain person right
he says consider the image of the plain
person this presents someone who is
initially a stranger to all moral
philosophies therefore unequipped with
resources provided by any particular
philosophical standpoint they begin from
a position of philosophical neutrality
taking her his first steps in the
direction of this or that philosophical
standpoint without the guidance of any
reasons which presupposed philosophical
commitment this is to leave the plain
person bereft of philosophical relevant
reasoning
so the counterpart of their neutrality
is a rationally unguided arbitrariness
in that person's initial choice of which
philosophical direction to take and he
says here we have a shock of recognition
right that is if we know the history of
ideas well
a says we've met this plain person
before not in the street or on the farm
but in the pages of a number of
philosophers since Kierkegaard
especially those of Jean-Paul sart of
the late 1940s this is the human being
constructed by existentialist
philosophical Theory disguised as a play
in person it's not truly a plain person
it's the plain person as John Paul sart
or pick whoever else represents them
right and we could say similar things
with a manual Kant who also like he says
manual kant's plain person who possesses
what Kant calls an ordinary rational
knowledge of morality is already a
proto-conscion Kant is projecting onto
his own time and persons his own moral
theory same thing with somebody who we
don't read very much anymore but was a
big name at the time Thomas Reed his
plain person does not possess mere
common sense but common sense as
articulated philosophically by Reed and
then he brings up Henry Sedgwick who
again many people don't read but Henry
Cedric talks about the ordinary you know
person and it just so happens that they
turn out to be like Sedgwick a
utilitarian right so you're not going to
have any
point of view on the plain person that
isn't question begging to some degree
even the ones that appear to be calling
out question begging right so he goes on
and he says that
let's recognize the plain person must
always be conceived as already somehow
or other engaged with philosophy in some
determinate way and we need to ask what
philosophical standpoint it is which is
implicit not explicit but implicit in
his or her initial attitudes
presuppositions and questions is are
they perhaps a proto-conscient or you
know a
proto-existentialist or are they perhaps
an Aristotelian and here he begins to
talk about again from an Aristotelian
point of view goal directiveness we are
goal directed uh beings we recognize
norms and goods and the question is can
we actually work these out well and he's
going to go into a discussion of what
Thomas Aquinas calls the inclinationes
which are ways of orienting ourselves
as human agents right and they were
provided with some sort of like
conclusions or precepts things that we
ought to follow that way and then we
also have what McIntyre calls practices
and practices you know it's sort of a
technical term within McIntyre practices
have internal Goods there are communal
ways of doing things so chess is a
practice phishing is a practice
family life can be a practice as he says
even moral philosophy is going to turn
out to be a practice by the time that we
get to the end of this or a certain kind
of moral philosophy and this means that
we also need to have as he points out
accounts of goods the things that we
consider desirable things we have to
like order in relation to each other
sometimes pass up some so we can have
others rules you know what sort of uh
directions should we be following these
universal codes you might say and when
should we make exceptions and then
virtues states of character like justice
or honesty or I mean there might be some
things that are actually vices in an
Aristotelian sense that people do
consider virtue like those who say that
greed is good you know now you can be
mistaken about all of this sort of thing
and every
philosophical point of view is going to
tackle these matters in one way or
another sometimes
focusing entirely on Goods like
utilitarianism tends to do and then
rules and virtues come secondarily right
or it might be deontological and you
focus primarily on the rules and the
other things you know fall into place
after that or it could be Aristotelian
which isn't just virtue ethics virtue
comes first all of these have to be
integrated with each other
so he is going to go on and much later
in the piece he's going to talk about
why he thinks the plain person is
fundamentally a
proto-aristicelian and he's going to say
there's three claims I'm making what
does what is involved in saying that a
plain person is a proto-aristotelian so
the first one he says every human being
either lives her lives out her his life
in a narrative form which is structured
in terms of a Telos a orientation a and
a purpose a final good a good that that
puts everything else in perspective of
Virtues and of rules an Aristotelian
mode or
they have disrupted that narrative by
committing her himself to some other way
of life which is best understood as an
alternative designed to avoid or escape
from an Aristotelian mode of life so the
lives of those who understand themselves
uh explicitly are much more probably
probably implicitly in terms set out by
Kant or Reed or Sedgwick or start are
still informed by this rejected
alternative so what is he saying there
there's a lot of verbiage
either you adopt something and not in
you know in a very explicit way but in
an implicit way that looks Aristotelian
or you're picking something else which
ended up developing historically as an
alternative to this Aristotelian point
of view broadly aristotelia not
necessarily coming straight out of
Aristotle's Nick and McCain ethics but
reflected in Traditions and practices
and communities so it's one or the other
you can't
get away from it any third alternative
would be over here in the other right
there's a whole bunch of alternatives
the other thing that he says after that
is uh this I've told the story of the
decline and follow the plain person as
The Narrative of a single wife but the
story could have been told and I have
told it elsewhere in after virtue as a
claim about the narrative history of a
set of successive periods in Western
culture from the 16th to the 20th
century and so he talks about a partial
mirroring of the fate of individuals in
the history of the larger social order
and the fate of that larger order these
are narratives that are inseparable
these these two stories so the choice
between aristotelianism or something
else it's not just individuals but also
our broader culture that's doing that
then the third thing that he's going to
say this is a a strong claim
I'm committed to holding every human
being as potentially a fully fledged and
not merely proto-aristotelian
so you know it's possible for any one of
us whether we're a moral philosopher or
not to become fully aristotelia in this
way and not just kind of incipiently
Aristotelian or implicitly at
Aristotelian and then he goes on further
and says
the frustration of that potentiality is
among his or her morally important
characteristics so those who have not
been allowed to develop or have not
themselves allowed their lives to
develop in an Aristotelian form there is
going to be a crucial and ineliminable
tension between that in them which is
and that which is not Aristotelian
so the standard modern or
antiaristotelian self will be a
particular kind of divided self
exhibiting that complexity so
characteristic of and so prized by
modernity but ultimately stuck in a kind
of inadequacy and unhappiness
so this is a set of very interesting
claims
he's going to go on a little bit further
with this towards the very end and he
you know this is after his discussion of
like well how should we bring up
Aristotle don't just put the nick of
McCain ethics in somebody's hand we need
to figure out how to help people apply
this within their own lives within the
stories of their lives but he he
concludes by saying that
um
it is not just that I said earlier
practices have an Aristotelian structure
right they're end oriented they involve
developing excellences or virtues they
have internal Goods it is also that
engaging in the practice notice what
he's calling here at practice of asking
seriously and systematically the
question what is my good doing moral
philosophy right
plain persons engage in a reflective
practice
with an Aristotelian content as well as
structure
so these are two important intertwined
matters he says that this is a practice
in which Aristotle and Aquinas and we
could add so many other people have
preceded them that's why we read the
Aristotle that's why we read the Aquinas
that's why we read you know other
potential interlocutors that way and so
he says it's less surprising than that
then we may have thought that those who
first come to a reading of the nick of
McCain ethics or you know the Primus may
already exhibit the cardinal virtues
without as yet knowing the reasons for
needing them
and it is not after all paradoxical to
assert that we must already have these
if we're going to understand why we need
them and so he says the nick of McCain
ethics and aquinas's commentary on it
and the Prima secunde of the sumatelogya
are texts now this is a beautiful
passage in which the readers are able to
discover themselves as characters
or rather to discover types of
characters which to some significant
degree they already
exemplify we find in these rather
abstract seemingly academic texts we
find ourselves in a story that can be
told about our own progress or our own
decline how we screwed up how we
actually fortunately succeeded
and this is all within as he says an
Aristotelian structure
but not just a structure
Aristotelian content is informing this
now not all Aristotelian content
Aristotle is wrong on some points if you
read Thomas Aquinas they'll say well
Aristotle got this right got this wrong
if you read McIntyre he will also say
that McIntyre himself is a Thomas
Aristotelian right
so this shows you the extent to which
McIntyre thinks that it's unavoidable
that the plain person is a A
proto-aristotelian or rejecting that is
going to go the wrong way even in
thinking that they're getting things
right and then find out later on so if
you want to be successful in the
practice of moral life which should be
important to you then for McIntyre you
want to gradually discover
the resources that aristotelianism
provides you with